[Music]
all right welcome back to another this
is actually a very special episode of
the careful boys where indeed we are
going to talk about what we actually
really think about one bark quan hot
tank what finally really feel and think
about this dude and what is the first
thing that came to your mind he's lazy
i'm just glad he's not here
yeah i'm sorry i'll say it he's weak i'm
glad i'm sitting next to him
he's weak he's super weak his butt's
really nice i'm a little harness of his
meat he has a giant ass but that wasn't
a first impression of it was it his butt
just recently got big he booty built it
can't give him credit for that for first
impressions i met bart the first time at
uh
they had a seminar at barbell brigade
that i went to so like my first
impression he was super nice to me was
it a bart seminar
it was a mark bell seminar oh so you
went to go see mark bell and you're like
who's this scrawny asian guy next to
there's a little [ __ ] guy and i was
like oh he's the owner of this gym oh
okay cool and then he was nice and then
yeah
he's just been nice to me i don't know
he's not nice here i guess
he invited me to his home i watched
fights at his house he got me a good
barbecue remember i don't know talking
about he doesn't do barbies for us
shout out bart but his squad's weak but
yeah we're cutting all this out i just
wish bart treated us like he treated
barbell you know he can't use any of
that thanks
or he treated us like he treats alex or
he treats us like
people maybe just you bro
it sounds like you have something to say
don't bring me into this about bar he
treats me pretty good actually like
we're trying to say that bart bullies
you in some way
yeah do you think bart bullies you i
like bart's okay um let what do i really
think about bar how long what was your
first impression of them yeah
when you first met i thought it was just
a gym bro it was [ __ ] in all show you
guys doing uncle chin uncle sam were
[ __ ]
have you seen him prior to meeting him
did you know like did you watch his
videos not really that's true we all met
and then we're like hold on we gotta do
our thing and then we get into the
outfits and we're like hi australia how
you doing yeah so i was genuinely like i
was like oh [ __ ] this is a thing like
people just act mad asian and then
everyone loves you because i wasn't that
was one of the unique things that
[ __ ] jk did right i was like oh i'm
asian but man that's really asian you
know what i mean um and then bart was
like bart you know when you see him when
you first see him you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah right
you think it's larger dude [ __ ]
tattoos and she got a [ __ ] little
chinese tattoo and [ __ ] on shin
life right military haircut you go
that's a [ __ ] comedian if i ever saw
him
and then he's all like
also kind of nice yeah you know when you
see an intimidating large dude that's
like nice you're like the [ __ ] is wrong
with you you know what i mean or like
what happened in your past but you're
just mad nice it was geo who's more
intimidating than him gio scared the
[ __ ] out of me first you [ __ ] scared
me because she has i don't know she
she's not trying to make a look but when
i say resting [ __ ] face she has
intimidating she's just very
intimidating and she's way taller than
me
so she looked down she's like hey what's
up nick and she patting me dunking on
you hello boy but she was very nice to
me but i was intimidated more than i was
when i met bart so they so the way that
they look is like oh [ __ ] and then you
actually talk to him you're like oh
you're nice yeah yeah geo's still
intimidating compared to martha yeah
yeah i agree with that i second that i
can see it because she's more quiet
whereas well it depends if it's like
half day on jk bart's already [ __ ]
asleep but if it's seven a.m in the
morning bart's really like it's already
half the way out of the videos but no
but geo is
geo could be more reserved i could see
that yeah yeah she's she's a lot more
reserved but first time i met bart i
felt the same way i thought he was he
was a big burly man and i was like yo
this dude thick like he's wide just met
him at the gym he
i think he came and trained
i did a kickboxing class when i was the
first time i met him i think
yeah i'm pretty sure so with like david
in him yeah yeah and i met him and he
was really nice and he was actually kind
of like sweet he was such a little
sweetheart
and he was kind of soft-spoken and i was
like he's like hey what's that man like
he's very sarcastic sometimes you make
jokes and i'll be like oh you were
joking i didn't it went over my head but
otherwise the more i got to know him the
more i realize that i don't like him
that much yeah that makes sense
i have like a strong distaste you know
how like people grow on you he grows
away from you
and he grows in general yeah he does
he's gotten way [ __ ] bigger oh that's
the other thing about bart he's he
changes weight all the time yeah about
to say he's like he's been like three
different people since i don't know
when you met him anthony he was probably
like my size yeah he's definitely
skinnier yeah you were also skinnier i
was also skinnier you were all skinnier
scrawny yeah i was like can i met i met
him at the roast at the timmy roast and
then i remember thinking that it was
your channel not i didn't think that he
had anything to do with the channel
other than is it because he didn't
introduce himself or did i or yeah you
were more talkative and then also i had
heard of you before i had never heard of
anybody in jk before except for you
because it was just through the
grapevine i think you had done something
at maker before and people talked about
joe malia for some reason like in my in
my area oh interesting people had told
me about joe and i thought your name was
joe molly i thought your full name was
to this day you're in my phone as
jomalia because i didn't i didn't know
what the [ __ ] your name joseph malia
sounds like a dictator right it's funny
but
to put it together as i was on the show
that i was like oh okay this this is
like okay got it but yeah
but i thought it was because you always
carry the whole show to be honest like i
think bart was like he was
really good at everybody needs a
sidekick yeah you're the star he's
holding you back too he adds equal
character but i just you know i don't
think you need him anymore no he's
holding you back big time i think you
should get rid of him you grow so much
more yeah if you didn't have bart
weighing you down
man and he was level you get hit
he's an anchor bro like especially when
he's sleepy and i gotta [ __ ] he's
like anchor protocol bro albatro you
have to get way louder is that alpha
trust usually when you're getting
loudest because you're trying to wake
him up he's trying to shock him
how does his mind work though like how
does he really think about scheduling
right because he's like so [ __ ] on
schedule he's uh i'm gonna wake up like
he said i gotta wake up at 3 30 in the
morning so i can get my workout in so i
could drive to jk news from vegas at
five get here at ten eat my [ __ ]
steak every single goddamn stick make an
egg and do my [ __ ] jam and butter on
my bread and [ __ ] like that and then
show up for four videos out of 20. and
then just passes out for like the rest
of the work unless he wants to diss me
then he comes awake yeah yeah oh hey
[ __ ] you anthony it's like the holy
ghost [ __ ] presides inside of him
[ __ ] you anthony
and then this part yeah
it's like it's only eight minutes oh
[ __ ] and he comes back
trying to end the conversation open up
right now about this experience i had in
my childhood
dude one time we for the fights
we me alex and gilbert because we do a
mma show uh podcast and we went and did
a live stream at the quan residence in
vegas and we were there until probably
like 10 o'clock it was about 10. and
we're sitting down shooting the [ __ ]
geos like kicking it with us you know we
guys recording the podcast at 10 yeah
we're doing a live stream with everybody
but we had finished by this time we had
finished so we already just like kind of
unwinding right and it's it's about to
be 11
and we're sitting and talking and we're
about to leave but we're standing by the
door all talking
and all of a sudden bart goes up
turns off all the lights in the house it
gets all dark geo's like hey man what
the [ __ ]
we're still talking
why are you turning off all the lights
he was literally trying to kick us out
he brought her shoes for us and was like
trying to shoot us out the [ __ ] door
that's what he does he'll do that to you
at 7
15. as the fights are starting he's like
uh you guys should probably get going
huh you invite you to a barbecue and at
6 30 he kicks you out before the main
event
i'll do that i was like yo i'm taking
nina to vegas for like a thing about but
he's like yeah dude you can stay in my
house you just come whenever i was like
dude i'll probably get in late we're
going to watch the show he's like no
it's no problem come back
[ __ ] get there we like just get into
like beatles love we're like barely
starting the show and he's like hey man
like what time are you going to be here
you know it's it's only because like
tiger's gotta wake up early and bob like
throws all this [ __ ] at me so literally
in the middle of beatles love i'm
sitting there booking a hotel room
[ __ ] last night because i feel so bad
i feel [ __ ] bad i'm like dude i'm not
trying to wake this fool up and like his
kid and [ __ ] he just gave me a key
when me and ryan stayed at bart's house
for jk ryan got there at like 12 o'clock
and they were like come on in dude let's
go and he stayed up and was kicking it
with us
we stayed up till like 1am he went to
bed like 1am but that's because he
didn't give him the raise that he gave
me and steve that's true yeah
we got sick oh [ __ ] i wasn't supposed to
say that
that's what i get in place of a race
more time with him
i mean it's it's sweet he just loves you
so we have a little bump yeah
that he was kicking it for so long and
then ultimately we turned in because we
wanted to [ __ ] go to bed if i was
like you sure you guys want to hang out
a little longer if you turn on all the
lights instead of turning them off
she tries to spend time with the
employees
that's nice of them that's so true
though because i remember when i was
homeless i would crash there all the
time
and then when i came over i think they
wanted to kick it because they're like
oh it's been like a while and then me
and i was like man we just had a real
long road trip dude so peace and they're
all sitting on the couch and i was like
[ __ ] i think they wanted to talk and
[ __ ] but we're so used to sleeping early
yeah with them yeah come over to their
house
just had a [ __ ] bang he's like all
right i'll stand for 45 let's see if he
got
he's [ __ ] down to five hour energy
and he goes let's have a conversation
until 11 30 p.m and i'm knocking out
dude i've seen that full fall asleep
just sitting in his chair just
completely falling asleep like in the
middle of everyone sitting in a circle
talking oh for sure he's been like that
though even when we were young like you
think that's some old man [ __ ] right we
would be at clubs like
everyone's dancing [ __ ] drunk
partying
he goes and finds a bench and you see
him in fetal just knocking the [ __ ] out
that happened to me once
once right that's normal because i mean
people
today's video is brought to you by
expressvpn
all right i like to travel a lot
and on my phone it's very sensitive you
know i got my crypto on there oh yeah i
got my socials on there i got my whole
life in there and god forbid that one
day someone sneaks in goes into
everything destroys all my man it would
be so damn difficult to gather up
everything and i do not ever want that
to happen so that's why i use a vpn on
my phone because when i connect to
different wi-fi's all over the different
world you know i might be at this
airport or i might be over here at this
hotel i might be like connecting at this
cafe who knows right i want to feel
extremely safe
did you know that if there's someone on
the same network as you and both of you
guys are unencrypted
they can hack into your information and
then these hackers can take your
information and sell it on the dark web
for a thousand dollars or more wow
that's a lot of money that's why it's so
important to encrypt your stuff i got
expressvpn on my phone i got it on my
laptop and it's so easy to use you
literally just click
and then it goes on just like that
so super easy to use to protect yourself
because identity theft is a crazy thing
right now especially with the internet
and everyone has their whole life on
there you got pictures you got your
information you got financial data so
it's really important to stay safe
but expressvpn is very easy to use okay
so hackers can't steal your sensitive
data because they have this encrypted
tunnel between your data and the
internet so it's like bamfo they just
like did a whole magic trick on you it's
super secure it'll take a hacker a
billion years to get through
expressvpn's
so it's not just like putting a
blindfold on him it's putting a
blindfold on the hacker making him spin
around with a [ __ ] bat and then
telling him go somewhere yeah take that
secure your online data today by going
to expressvpn.com
off the record e-x-p-r-e
off the record and you can get an extra
three months for free
expressvpn.com off the record always get
one
this fool is like
at 10 30 starts getting tired around
midnight
we'll be at the [ __ ] club or a party
or somewhere and he's sleeping so good
he seems like he gets like a he can
recharge a lot off of like a really
quick nap
he naps half the time we're here he like
goes in the [ __ ] background i'm
surprised because like it was like after
we we took a break and then we're about
to start filming he's all hey let me
know when we started to take a nap i was
like we're starting like two minutes
he's like yeah cool and then he gets
back and he's like super energized like
from that you just shut you took a long
blink it's very military yeah it's like
a military skill right yeah he could
sleep
really quick like i used to um live with
him like when you live when you went to
ucla i would go visit all the time right
and i was dating his roommate at the
time and then so like we would be
chilling
and we're talking you know how like the
room's like dark but like we're all
being you know our beds and just talking
and we can hear his voice and then he'll
be responding and then in the middle of
the conversation you hear
and we're like bar
and we're like oh [ __ ] that we just fell
asleep while we were talking
in the middle so we rolled over and
started [ __ ]
really
you [ __ ] bart that's sick
while he was asleep whoa
he's just rolling the motor stop [ __ ]
don't wake daddy
why the [ __ ] probably the thing that i
you know as i got to know him
because i think i'm one of like the last
people who like rolled under the gate
before bart closed the friendship doors
kind of
oh his quota his quota was hit yeah he's
like you know i think we all kind of did
that when we hit a certain age but like
you know i feel like i took him one of
his most closest recent most recent
friends at the same time but i didn't
know what a what a shy dude that he is
like in there you know because he's an
introvert he's a super introverted
full-on introvert he's super interesting
also to observe everything that he does
he's sort of like nicking away where
everything that he does turns you on
i like to see his ass
everything he does everything he does
i'm always like
how where did you even come up with that
you're that you're capable of doing
something like that but he but he just
pulls something else out of a hat and
i'm always like [ __ ] of course bart's
gonna launch like a but protein powder
and like you know he's going to have a
pre-workout and all kinds of [ __ ] it's
just he's dude he's such a monster with
that stuff i'm really i'm really proud
of that dude it's fun to watch him
initiative and resolve is like
impressive it's funny because the
12-month part of the video where he
starts saying nice things all right [ __ ]
this guy all right he's cool i like him
to me it's a it's it's really dope
having him as a business partner though
because
you
um
you know just hearing all these other
people's like
experiences in business with with their
partners and whatever like there's a lot
of ego involved right like i got [ __ ]
lucky that he doesn't do any of that
[ __ ] when it comes to like his pride or
what he wants out of the company he's
just like there for the cause
and it's been consistently that so he's
just down ass [ __ ] yeah he is a dynamic
let's get this oh that's why he'll wake
up at three in the morning get his
workout in and then drive down from
vegas and do the show with us because he
could say i'm coming tomorrow and then
like i'll find a fill in and this is
like you'll consistently hit this this
is the first time where he was like all
right i gotta dip for like the whole
weekend yeah and
next month he was even like dude i feel
bad i gotta dip again because i'm gonna
do the basketball game in toronto and
i'm like yeah but jk making the presents
there that's yeah that's that's legit
like you got to play with jeremy lin and
see me because they don't want to play
with me dude you're bert swan you gotta
[ __ ] go play over there
yeah also knowing him pre-taika like
where he was i mean he really is like a
lot always the same dude but but seeing
watching him become a father has been
[ __ ] interesting because he's like
all the [ __ ] that he puts into like all
the stuff that he does he puts even more
of that into taika so it's like it's
really cool to see man he's probably
like one of the first people i would go
to if i'm a dad or i'm like yo what what
the [ __ ] going on with this yeah even
the way that he had taika get into jiu
jitsu right he said that the first day
tyga didn't want to [ __ ] go and he's
like man i don't think he's gonna like
it and i'm like so what are you gonna do
kick his ass cause i was like thinking
maybe he would asian data and he's like
nah i think i want him to like love the
sport so i was like all right so just
yell at him
and then he's like no like i think i'm
just gonna
you know just just wait it out and then
do it consistently so he says like over
a period of weeks or or a month or
whatever they would just go and hang out
there no pressure to do it and every
single time i was like dude i think
that's like what everybody probably
wanted out of their parents that's the
right way to do it honestly yeah because
i just like you're wasting my [ __ ]
money i'm paying a lot of money for
these lessons so you better get good
that's the right way that is right it
works though it's like the cleaner
player you're not going to [ __ ] like
yeah you're going to bed hungry and [ __ ]
that worked on me like crazy
it's a new era now though these kids
these kids aren't taking that [ __ ]
anymore the old ways don't work yeah we
have rights now because now their
parents are bullying them or they're
they're it's like some kind of damaging
them if they're forced to eat yeah
one of the funniest things too is i
remember when i first met you guys like
14 freaking years ago or something and
then uh when
you guys invited me to be on like when
when jk was all sketches and [ __ ] and
then i just remember thinking like
before i met them i was like
i've seen these guys they're [ __ ]
nuts i was like they're crazy they're
probably crazier than we are and then uh
you mean we as in quest
yeah your guys's moves are crazy but i
thought you guys were like gonna be all
like wild because i'm like from all your
videos my dudes are gonna be [ __ ]
nuts and then it's like the exact
opposite like production-wise like being
there everything's so well organized and
at the time i think geo was like the
producer and it like i had never seen
anyone do anything at that scale in
terms of like asian creators at the time
you know like this
[ __ ]
and it's funny because now that's like
whatever everybody does that but like
that wasn't even common back then i
remember thinking dude this big dude's
pretty [ __ ] was a big teddy bear
he really is a giant teddy bear it was
and he's like super nice and then
everything was like it was like a really
interesting impression i got i was like
oh so you could you could execute as
[ __ ] crazy as you want but then in
terms of like the back end and like
structure like you can actually have a
really successful like tight-knit thing
yeah and it's cool
yeah i was actually surprised with how
nice bart was to me off the jump and i
was like dude you didn't even know where
the [ __ ] i am i could be crazy and
you're being so nice to me so you gotta
be nice to those types of people i've
never seen them being fully to anybody
like like even annoying people
i was just like very patient dude
dude he's never been mad at me yelled at
me none of that [ __ ] i know he has anger
problems though like
what do you feel like what do you feel
like he like flips out over
he just beats geo that's why
i know for a fact he gets angry about
things
and he's like fought with other people
and things like that but like nah he's
never been mad at me
um i've been [ __ ] yelling at him and
mad at him but like he's never been mad
at me and um yeah i know i know like
other stories of other people he got mad
at but yeah i've never seen it that's
pretty interesting to be friends that
freaking long and he's never been like
managing yeah he might also just have
this like uh
ability to
compartmentalize especially when it
comes to like work related stuff because
he's like he's like sucking a picture of
him instead
you know what i mean though he's so like
um it's not like a weird meticulous but
he has such an attention to detail and a
logic
a foundation of logic that he applies
to almost any situation it's like well
if this then this like well why would
you do this when you should do this or
like that's a problem so i'm gonna focus
on you know what i mean it's just so
when he thinks business and i can
imagine outside of business stuff when
things are just like you know the
sporadic-ness of life maybe but maybe
it's i don't i'm guessing it's the
military i'm guessing it's the [ __ ] he
did in high school and yeah coming back
around to college and stuff like that
it's like he said in that video where he
beat up his bunk his [ __ ] roommate
yeah where he was like if you want to
discuss he's always open to discuss but
that dude just said [ __ ] you so he
started wailing him start blasting and
think of all the things he's been
through even just to the neiman marcus
it's funnier to say marcus now
monaco i'm gonna [ __ ] hide in a
grandfather clock because he's getting
his ass beat grandfather clocks will
always be fresh there's so much to learn
from that like being able to see the
humor and your dad [ __ ] stalking you
like silent hill
and turning your life into that yeah i
mean i'm impressed i used to live with
bart's dad and i feel like
the funny thing is i lived with bart's
dad but bart wasn't living there he had
an extra room and you guys are wild yeah
and then um that's another level you
guys have so many crazy sitcoms
man hello what the [ __ ] yeah
but um i got to know why bart is the way
bart is by meeting and knowing his
parents
his dad can [ __ ] remember everything
without a calendar
because his his life is like clockwork
and he gets mad because he's like why
can't you just remember normal [ __ ]
every tuesday of the first tuesday of
every month we [ __ ] steam clean the
whole entire house you're supposed to
just leave your things and this i'm like
[ __ ] bro that's crazy who remembers that
he and then you'll be like hey we're
gonna go eat on the 27th at uh six
o'clock we're gonna go to this
restaurant you'll be like all right i'll
be there and he'll just show up five
minutes early so like oh without like
going hey we're meeting up today no he
just he's like he's remembering it from
a month ago huh and then he's the most
repetitive
scheduled dude and then you start when
you live with someone you start to
notice like certain patterns
he makes soup on sunday and then he eats
that throughout the first three days and
then he cooks whatever he wants for the
rest of the week um he has his work
schedule probably shits at the same time
every day too bro and then like if he's
a [ __ ] serial killer he'll watch
something
non-stop so he'll binge through dude for
two months toby maguire's spider-man
because then i'll get it yeah it seems
to be the chinese military parade oh
yeah on his [ __ ] repeat bro he would
watch so he hates communist china
because he ran away from china to come
to america right he's swami i don't
understand the logic but this is what
this is what bart told me is that even
though he hates communist china he loves
watching the parade because it's like
the accomplishment of chinese people
so then so then i'm like that makes no
sense to me because if you hate the
[ __ ] communist that's like he's a
down ass [ __ ] though right that's where
it comes from yeah and then all so so so
he has this people so he watches his
parade for two months straight every
single day after work he i go downstairs
he's watching the parade same one when
the parade ends he goes man that [ __ ]
was sick and he has to [ __ ] do it on
repeat like it was like how do you watch
a [ __ ] parade what are you talking
about watching a parade sounds awful ugh
he's just sitting down
and he watches a parade
i just don't really get that
top five parades everyone why is it
sometimes he watches it now is it this
china seller 70th anniversary oh no
probably something else just the china
military parade some cctv things it's
like china
military guys [ __ ] a rocket a tank is
there a pride parade in china
no
can you imagine that you get the china
pride parade okay so it's like this [ __ ]
yes yeah just like that and and it's
it's back pretty impressive
photography is on point though is it
north korea no that's china right this
is better than the rose bowl parade the
colors are more dynamic
yeah so imagine this crispy look at it
like a like a like a hour of it and he
just plays it one of those guys who like
loved searing it like you know ant
colonies dude this is sick though okay
i love that live music or
this is not good
they're playing it there's a band
playing in it
that's not their music bro
there's
chinese parades and van halen trivia
bands
[Music]
[Music]
you